[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA HAMDAN: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for being here
for this exciting Google talk,
exciting for two reasons today.
One is because we are the first
to be doing it in this room.
Yay.
And second because we have
with us a very famous movie
director, Ali Mostafa.
Not many people can
say that they've
been credited with such amazing
success on a personal scale,
but also on a kind
of regional level.
So his film "City of
Light" is actually
credited with being the
first Emirati feature
film, which is huge.
And it's kind of changed
the face of Dubai cinema.
So we're going to hear about
this journey, how he even
began all of this.
We're very keen to hear
about your creative process,
your creativity.
So I just want to start with
how did you get into filmmaking?
I think it's a dream we
all have when we're young.
It sounds very glamorous.
Why did you choose
it as a career?
ALI MOSTAFA: Well, thank
you all for being here.
Thank you for having
me, first of all.
I just want to make a
small little correction.
Yes, it is labeled as the
first Emirati feature film.
But technically, it
isn't because there
was a film that was released.
It may not have gotten
a theatrical release,
but there was a
feature-length film
that was made prior to mine.
It was only because mine was
on an international scale,
and it did quite well
in the box office
that they labeled
it as the first.
So let's get that
technicality out of the way.
SARA HAMDAN: If it's on
the internet, it's real.
ALI MOSTAFA: Exactly.
There's no fake news there, no.
So I started-- how did I start?
Well, since I was a child, ever
since I was nine years old,
I've been making films.
And when I say
making films, I've
been taking my
parents video camera
and shooting my toys
and my younger brothers
and whatever I could do.
It started, I guess, with this
massive Betamax collection.
I don't know how many of you
remember what Betamaxes are.
OK, it was before VHS.
There was the little
ones called Betamax.
And he had a massive collection.
Actually, my father
always managed
to start a collection of things
that were bound to be obsolete,
which was the Betamax, and then
he later went to LaserDiscs.
Anyway, that's another story.
So I watched "Star Wars"
for the first time.
And I was, like, blown away.
I said, I wanted to be
the guy who created that.
There's a lot of
times that people
would watch something and say
they want to be the person who
was acting in it, or they
want to be the person who
was involved in such and such.
I immediately knew
I wanted to be
the guy in the background who
kind of created that world.
And so when I watched
"Star Wars" and, obviously,
a lot of stuff from George Lucas
and Spielberg-- it was "Jaws."
It was "Star Wars,"
"Indiana Jones,"
stuff like that that really,
really got me excited.
And then when I saw--
it was to me, it was the first
kind of epic Arab kind of film.
It was called "Ar-Risalah,"
which translates "The Message."
It was by, God rest his
soul, Moustapha Akkad, who
was very well known
for having produced
the "Halloween" movies,
those horror films.
So after seeing that and seeing
the scale of that film, I said,
you know what?
There is a chance for
someone in the Arab world
to be able to do
something like that.
And so it was always
a dream of mine.
So from stealing my parents
camera to eventually getting
having one given to me
as a birthday present,
to then doing
stop-motion animation--
SARA HAMDAN: So they
sound really supportive.
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh, yeah.
They were supportive because
that's all I kind of did.
It was either filming my toys
or doing stunts and filming
myself doing stunts.
Actually, I was
torn between being
a stuntman or a filmmaker.
SARA HAMDAN: I wanted to
be a costume designer.
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh, yeah?
SARA HAMDAN: [INAUDIBLE]
ALI MOSTAFA: So yeah.
So yeah, so basically, that's
how it really all started.
It started from
when I was a child
and how my parents
really supported me.
SARA HAMDAN: And
then you studied
film And was "City of Light"--
what was your first project?
ALI MOSTAFA: OK, so there was a
lot that happened before that.
So I was doing film, obviously
childish amateur stuff.
And then before graduating
from high school,
I had a lot of friends that were
about 10 years older than me.
And they were all
working at the time.
And so they were all
having their own income.
And I was still on
like a pocket money.
SARA HAMDAN: Allowance?
ALI MOSTAFA: Allowance.
And so I really wanted to
start having my own money
and feeling a little
bit more responsible.
And my mother has
an events company
called Blooms, which started
as a flower shop in the '80s.
And she has a trade license
for interior design.
Now, I grew up in a household
where my father's an architect.
My mother was doing a lot of
events and creative stuff.
So I got to see how a
lot of stuff was built.
And I was also blessed to be
able to sketch and draw things
from a very young age.
So I went to her and said,
you have this trade license.
You're not really
doing much with it
because you're focused
on other things.
What if I set up a division of
interior design with you guys?
And the first thing I did was
design my sister's wedding
stage.
Now, in this part of the
world, weddings are massive.
And you would have the
wedding stage to be themed.
SARA HAMDAN: This should
be your next film.
ALI MOSTAFA: What,
my life story?
SARA HAMDAN: The wedding.
Have an Arab wedding.
ALI MOSTAFA: So basically--
yeah, there's one, as well.
So basically, you have
these massive wedding stages
that are themed.
And my sister's wedding stage
was a secret garden theme.
So that was my--
and I designed it, sketched
it, and then we built it.
And kind of my wedding stage
career kicked off after that.
SARA HAMDAN: Wow.
ALI MOSTAFA: And I was
just doing wedding stages
for about a year and a half.
I had about 30
people underneath me
in terms of people who
were working for me.
And we were building
these wedding stages.
And I became really
popular doing this.
And then I reached a point--
and this is before
graduating from high school.
So I graduated from high school.
And that's what I kind
of did for a while.
And I'm like, I have
to actually stop
what I'm doing because
my goal is to make films.
I just started this as
something to just make
a bit of money on the side.
I wish I didn't stop
it because I was
making a lot more money then.
But anyway, so basically,
I stopped that.
And I started searching
for film schools.
And I looked everywhere.
I looked in New York, Los
Angeles, all the places
in Europe.
And then I found this one that
I was really comfortable with,
which was the
London Film School.
And it was close to 50
years as a film school.
But unfortunately, it
was a master's course.
And so when I graduated
from high school,
I started this division
in this company.
And I was working for a while.
So I didn't even go
and do my bachelor's.
But then I saw that you needed
a few things to actually get
into the school.
Number one, you needed to
have some kind of, like, work
experience in the industry.
You needed to have made a
short film, critique a script,
and do a storyboard.
So I gathered all of
my wedding stages,
and I put it in this portfolio.
And I sent it to the
school as though it
was a production design,
which is a part of filmmaking.
SARA HAMDAN: Yeah, true.
ALI MOSTAFA: Because you know,
you're building sets and films.
And what we do in
wedding stages,
we're literally building sets,
and then taking them down.
So I got into the
London film school.
SARA HAMDAN: Based on your work.
ALI MOSTAFA: Based on my work.
So I ended up--
SARA HAMDAN: That's amazing.
ALI MOSTAFA: --skipping the
bachelor's, and I went straight
to a master's.
SARA HAMDAN: So independent,
ambitious, creative,
think outside the box.
ALI MOSTAFA: Think
outside the box.
SARA HAMDAN: That's
your personality.
And I feel like I can describe
"City of Light" the same way.
I mean, I don't know how many
of you have seen this film.
But the reason why I agreed
to moderate this talk
is because I loved it.
I found it extremely--
all the things I just said,
but also controversial.
Can you tell us a
little bit about it
for those who haven't
seen it and are
going to run out and see
it immediately after this?
ALI MOSTAFA: Right.
Well, I don't know if you'd feel
the same way about seeing it
now.
That film was done
almost 10 years ago.
So "City of Life" was--
so after graduating
from film school,
I wanted to get
into the industry.
So I think I should say this
before actually going straight
to "City of Life" because it
was a journey to actually get
to "City of Life."
"City of Life" was a
film that I wanted to do.
But after graduating
from film school,
I had to do a graduation film.
And in order to do
the graduation film,
you had to kind of select
where you wanted to do it.
So I picked Dubai.
And it was the first
film or short film
or whatever film of
any capacity that
was shot on celluloid,
which was meaning we
shot it on 16-millimeter.
And that was in 2003.
And I was shocked.
I'm like, is this really the
first film to be shot on film?
And that short film went on to
a competition in the country
to win Best Emirati Film amongst
many other Emirati films.
It was actually
quite surprising.
We had a lot more people
interested in film
those days than they are now.
So fast forward.
Trying to get into an industry,
the only industry that
existed here was a
commercial industry,
which I ended up
trying to get myself
on as many sets
as possible, where
I was helping with the grip
department, the gaffers, and--
I don't know, these are
all terms used in film.
But the gaffer is a guy who's
in charge of the lighting.
The grip's the guys in
charge of what you would
have as a tripod or a dolley.
So that would be
the grip department.
So I would be helping
all of these departments
until eventually, I
would go and become
a third assistant director.
I was fourth for a
very short period,
but third assistant
director, where
I'd control a crowd
in a football stadium
for a beverage
commercial, where we have
to move the crowd from
one side to the other,
and just screaming
down a megaphone,
to becoming a second
assistant, trying
to get myself as close
to director as possible,
till eventually becoming
an assistant director,
and then wanting to
make my own commercial.
That's a story on its own.
But eventually--
SARA HAMDAN: We'll
definitely get back
to that later
because a lot of us
work with advertisers
and brands.
ALI MOSTAFA: Right.
SARA HAMDAN: And we do
want to learn about that.
But about your film first.
ALI MOSTAFA: Right.
So to skip all of that, I had
to stop getting into commercials
because it was
something that you were
kind of getting sucked into it.
SARA HAMDAN: A different path.
ALI MOSTAFA: A different path.
So I had to stop
doing commercials.
And as you can imagine,
it was a very tough period
for kind of just
stopping work entirely
because I was married at the
time, trying to start a family.
And I didn't have a job.
I had to stop it and
focus on my dream, which
was making this film.
I remember selling my car
to fund my first script.
Anyway, 28 scripts later,
I came up with this idea.
And this was around
the time where
Dubai was being bashed a lot.
There was a lot of Dubai
bashing going on in the West.
You know, calling it this fake
place, this artificial place,
it's made of plastic
fantastic and all of that.
And it was something that
was affecting me because it
was a place that I grew up in.
And them calling it soulless, I
said, how can you call a place
that all of us grew up in
something that was soulless?
Yes, it's evolved
in an amazing way.
But it wasn't
soulless, you know?
So I decided that I wanted
to try and make a film that
spoke about the Dubai I knew.
So I did-- it was a film that
was about three characters.
There was an Indian taxi driver.
And the entire part of that
film was spoken in Hindi.
Then we had the
Western characters,
the Western storyline,
which was in English.
And then you had the
Emirati storyline,
which quite a lot,
actually, was based
on events that happened
in my life, which
was spoken in Arabic.
So there was three
languages, three characters,
and it was very much
a Dubai-centric film.
And I remember when we got
to start making that film--
even though that again, that's
a huge story for it to get off
the ground because that film
took me almost five years,
four and a half years
to make that film.
And how we even got to
making that film-- but once
the film was made and
released, it really
had this buzz around it because
it was something that was never
done before at the time.
It was something that
spoke to so many people.
And it for a good nine years
held a record in how long
it lasted and how well
it did in the box office.
SARA HAMDAN: I
remember when I first
heard that this film
came out about Dubai,
and I'd been living
here for about 10 years.
I was excited to see it.
But I was also taking
it with a grain of salt
because I thought
it must be censored,
or it's going to just
be happy happy, light.
But he's been very
humble about it.
It's powerful because just from
what I remember from seeing it
so long ago, the characters go
through some really emotional
things that you wouldn't expect
to see in a movie in Dubai
at the time, especially.
So there's a stewardess who
gets pregnant out of wedlock.
There is an Emirati
man who loses--
I can't remember if it's a
brother or a best friend?
ALI MOSTAFA: Best friend.
SARA HAMDAN: His best friend
and develops a drinking problem.
So you see an Emirati drinking.
These are very, very strong
themes to tackle long ago.
So I have to ask, how
did you get away with it?
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh, by
the skin of my teeth.
That's for sure.
Because not a lot
of people know this,
but the film was banned at one
point before being released.
And this was even
before it was released.
So it was--
OK, I guess I'm going
to have to get into it.
Before making the
film, in the country,
you have to go to what is
called the National Media
Council, which you can't shoot
anything here unless you've
got script approval.
You need to get a certificate
from the National Media
Council giving you
approval to make a film
and based on the
script or whatever.
So it was six months of
driving back and forth
to Abu Dhabi of them rejecting
the script, of me trying
to convince them how this is
important for the industry,
and we have to be talking
about things like this,
even though I was only
scratching the surface when
it comes to controversy.
But there needs
to be some drama,
and this is what we have to do.
And it just kept
getting rejected.
And I think they got sick
and tired of seeing my face,
where there was a
compromise of OK,
this is what's going to happen.
And by the way, in the
four and a half years,
I managed to raise about $5
million to make this film.
OK?
And a guy who's never
made a film before,
so that's a story on its own.
So I got to a point where
they said, you know what?
OK, shoot the film.
And once it's finished,
we will watch it,
and then we will decide.
So imagine the pressure of
shooting your first film where
only you and the producer know
stepping onto set every day
that it might never
see the light of day.
So we go ahead.
We make the film.
There's this huge buzz,
again, around the film
because there's press
hearing about it.
They're seeing us
shooting on the streets.
We're, like, on
[INAUDIBLE] Road.
We're by the desert.
We're around Dubai.
There's this buzz about this--
it's the first big
production Emirati film.
And then we reach a point where
I have to now screen the film.
So I gather everyone.
I rent a screening room
in one of the hotels here.
And so all of kind of like
the heads of media show up.
And they watch the film.
And I'm in a room
similar to this.
And I'm standing at
the back by the door.
And the film finishes.
The credits roll.
A bit of silence.
People leave.
And one by one, they look at me.
OK, nice movie.
Nice movie.
And they start leaving.
And I'm like, OK.
So I run to the valet,
where everyone's
waiting for their car.
And I say, so do I
get the approval?
He said, listen, you
know, it's a very strong--
it's a good film.
But why don't you
speak to that guy?
So OK.
So I go to that guy.
And I ask him, so what
do you think of the film?
They said, well, you
know, I think it's--
I think maybe better you
speak to that person.
SARA HAMDAN: Nobody
wanted the responsibility.
ALI MOSTAFA: They were
passing the buck, which--
it was understandable also.
Looking back at it, I mean, it
was something that was so new.
And no one knew
what you were going
to do with something like this.
Till eventually, one
of the guys there
was the director of Dubai
International Film Festival.
He realized that no one
really said anything.
I want to premiere this at
my festival, which would
be the Dubai Film Festival.
SARA HAMDAN: That's
where I saw it.
ALI MOSTAFA: We announced it.
It's going to be in
Dubai Film Festival.
Three weeks prior to the
festival, I got a call--
three or four weeks.
I got a call saying, Ali, I am
sorry to give you this news.
You're about to receive a fax.
It was fax.
Those days, it was fax.
Receive a fax.
I said, OK.
Sorry, here's the fax is coming.
My hands are tied.
[BUZZING] You know,
the fax comes through.
I rip it out.
And I read it.
And it's an official letter from
a very high place in the media,
signed by the head of
the media at that time,
and saying, this film
will not be screened,
showcased in any shape or form.
It was pretty bad.
And so I got a call back
saying, so what do you do?
I said, I'm not
gonna listen to that.
It's impossible.
You can't listen to
someone, this person who
made this decision on
something like this.
We've just four and a half years
of trying to make this film,
finally getting it there,
getting a platform in Dubai
Film Festival, everyone
being excited about it,
and then because someone being
a little bit closed-minded,
for it to just vanish--
obviously, we would not
have a film industry.
We still, by the way, don't.
We're getting there, but
it's really moving fast.
But we would not be anywhere
had we not really pushed
for this film.
So what I decided, and God bless
our leaders in this country,
is that I decided--
I said, look, I did
not make this film
based on that individual city.
I made it on His Highness
Sheikh Mohammad's city.
Now, if his highness says, I
don't want to screen this film,
I will shut up.
You know?
So what I did is I managed
to speak to someone.
Actually, it was one of the
lead actors in "City of Life."
And I told him to
come to the house.
I said, look, this
is what we received.
He was obviously surprised.
And this guy grew
up in the media,
since he was a presenter
since he was nine years old.
I said, look, I need you to
take this film to his highness
and tell him the fate
of Emirati cinema lies
on your decision of this movie.
He's like, [NON-ENGLISH]
which means I'll do it.
And he goes ahead.
A couple of weeks later,
I was in another festival
for something else.
And I was with my producer.
And we were trying to
figure out this rescue
plan, what are we going to do?
And I think it was
two weeks later.
It might have been
And he told me the story.
He said he had
gone to the palace.
And his highness was leaving
with the king of Bahrain,
as he was on his way.
And he saw the guy.
And he went up to him.
He said, listen,
I have this movie.
And he said those words.
And Sheikh Mohammed
actually visited
set when we were shooting.
I don't know if he
intentionally visited,
but he was driving past
and saw a shooting,
so he came to see
what was going on.
So when he found out that
he's presenting the film,
he's like, oh, so the
film is not released?
It's not made?
He was unaware and
was given the film.
And I got a call
two weeks later.
And I saw it was him.
Well, not his highness.
It was [INAUDIBLE],,
who I gave the film to.
And I answered the phone.
And he was screaming
down the phone.
And he was yelling,
screaming, [ARABIC]..
And I just was silent,
and I was listening.
And I said, so what happened?
He's like, Sheikh Mohammed
called me just now
and said that he thought
it was a great film.
And he said that we should be
very proud of what we achieved.
And he goes, but is it approved?
He goes, of course
it's approved.
And if you need any support in
the future, just let us know.
And I had just a
tear run down my eye.
And I was like--
you know, this was,
like, almost five years
of trying to make this film.
And then I was like, no
one can say anything now.
This film is getting
its world premiere
in Dubai Film Festival.
And it did.
It got its premiere.
And it did as well as it did.
And I knew.
I knew with the
vision of the leaders
that we have today that they
would understand the vision we
had with this movie.
The movie was not
sugarcoating Dubai.
SARA HAMDAN: Not at all.
ALI MOSTAFA: It was
making it a real place.
And this is what we were trying
to achieve with this film.
So yes, that's how we
dealt with the controversy.
SARA HAMDAN: Round of applause.
ALI MOSTAFA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Not to me.
It's for them.
SARA HAMDAN: And also,
round of applause
for having friends
in high places.
ALI MOSTAFA: Does help.
SARA HAMDAN: But after
such a big success--
I imagine this is something
that a lot of artists face--
what comes next?
How do you top that?
It's hard.
ALI MOSTAFA: Yeah,
you think its going
to happen very quickly
after that, you know?
You become almost this
poster boy for a little bit.
And you go, oh, I'm going to
make my new film very quickly.
And then you realize,
what is my next movie?
What is it going to be about?
And I was stumped.
I didn't know what
I wanted to do.
Do I make another drama?
Do I make a comedy?
Do I make a musical?
What do I do?
And then it was trying to run
around and think of ideas.
Who's going to then fund it?
I have to start raising money
again, come up with a script.
I love the idea of road
films, like road-trip movies.
And I also wanted
to do a comedy.
I also kind of wanted to tap
into a very different genre
to "City of Life."
So four and a half
years later of trying
to make my second
feature, we made
a film called "From
A to B," which
is from Abu Dhabi to Beirut,
about a group of friends who
take that journey from
Abu Dhabi to Beirut
in honor of their friend that
they have lost in high school.
That film became the
first Emirati film
to be the opening-night film
at the Abu Dhabi Film Festival,
which was quite a
big deal at the time,
although it was the
first and last Emirati
film to open because
Abu Dhabi Film Festival
the year after was no more.
But it was a very exciting
time because for many years--
and even in Dubai,
by the way, there's
been no Emirati film to
actually open the festival.
"City of Life" was
the first Emirati film
to have a gala on
the red carpet.
But there was no film
to open the festival.
So after many years of
it being around, for us
to get given that recognition
and that platform of being
opening night was great.
So yeah, that's how we
did our second film.
SARA HAMDAN: What do you think
of the UAE's film industry now?
You're saying things like there
aren't that many filmmakers.
I imagine there aren't
that many role models.
Film festivals
are shutting down.
You're painting a pretty
bleak picture here.
ALI MOSTAFA: Well, I
wouldn't say bleak.
It's definitely positive--
well, except for that festival
closing down.
But there's a reason that
festival closed down.
The reason I'm aware of is
because there was twofour54,
Image Nation Abu Dhabi.
And they realized--
I mean, the country, yes, we
are the United Arab Emirates.
A lot of people feel we're not
united, but we're very united.
And they realized, we have
a massive festival in Dubai.
Why was it needed to have a
second festival in Abu Dhabi
that a lot of the money that
was going to that festival
could be put in the
arts and culture,
like Image Nation
and funding films
and stuff that's
happening like the Louvre?
You know?
So that was one of
the main reasons.
And in terms of the
industry being--
when I say there's a positive
outlook on what's happening,
it's because it is
really moving fast.
Last year in Dubai
Film Festival,
we had 13 Emirati films.
Not necessarily features, but
there were 13 films over there.
Last year in the theaters, we
had about three Emirati films
playing.
It used to be one Emirati
film every two years.
You know what I mean?
SARA HAMDAN: So it's growing.
ALI MOSTAFA: So it is growing.
And obviously, we are
such a small industry.
And again, I don't want
to call it an industry.
I would like to call
it more of a movement
because an industry
sustains itself.
And we're not there yet.
But we will get
there fairly soon.
And how we've moved so fast
from when we made "City of Life"
in 2009 to where
we are now in 2018
is an amazing leap, even
when it comes to censorship.
Because to me, "A to B" is
a lot more controversial
than "City of Life," and I
got approval in six days.
You know?
SARA HAMDAN: Because they
know who you know now.
ALI MOSTAFA: No.
SARA HAMDAN: No, I'm kidding.
Because they've seen your work.
I'd like to jump back really
quickly to the commercials
that you've done.
So after that stint before you
released the big groundbreaking
film, did you go back
to commercials at all?
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh,
yeah, of course.
SARA HAMDAN: So you
continued to do them?
ALI MOSTAFA: And I have to.
I mean, commercials really
is my bread and butter.
SARA HAMDAN: You've worked
for some really big brands, as
well, right?
ALI MOSTAFA: Yeah.
Yeah, I was very lucky
to be able to do that.
SARA HAMDAN: Like?
ALI MOSTAFA: Land Rover.
Not only did I work
with Land Rover
in shooting a
commercial for them,
I represented them
as an ambassador
for about five years.
So I worked with [? Etisalat, ?]
[? Vilbrequin, ?] top,
top brands.
And actually, the latest
commercial that I've I done,
which I think came
out yesterday,
which I'm really
excited about because it
was by DU, the telecom company.
And last year, they started a
campaign called #PostWisely.
It was basically based on how
people just post everything
on social media.
And it was based
on these two events
where someone sees
that this guy,
he posted his boarding pass.
He's in this country.
And he just had his
whole house robbed.
Or this person posting
their child in this park,
and then they had someone want
to try and kidnap their child.
So it's about sharing your
entire life on social media.
So that was last
year's campaign.
And this year's campaign--
and that was all done in the UK.
So I was very lucky
to be asked to direct
the ones for this
year, where it to me
was even a bigger technical
achievement because they wanted
to do the entire thing from
the perspective of the victim.
So it was a point-of-view film.
And it's a film where
they would have--
there was actually a thing,
a very drastic thing,
that happened in Kuwait where
an employee, a Kuwaiti woman,
was filming her maid hanging
from the side of the building
screaming for help.
And she was just filming her
until she kind of lost her grip
and fell seven stories.
SARA HAMDAN: Oh, wow.
ALI MOSTAFA: Luckily
she survived.
She landed on, like, a 2 by
4 aluminum roof and survived.
But there's quite a lot of cases
like that, where people drive
by car accidents and
then film dead bodies
or mutilated bodies.
And then they have
these bullies in school
who are bullying this person,
and people are just filming it.
You know?
And instead of
taking that footage
to the authorities or the
headmaster or whatever,
they're sharing it
on social media.
SARA HAMDAN: There's a
good "Black Mirror" episode
about this.
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh, yeah?
SARA HAMDAN: If anyone's
seen the show on Netflix.
ALI MOSTAFA: So
we've-- actually,
I'm still to watch
"Black Mirror."
SARA HAMDAN: It's very good.
ALI MOSTAFA: I heard.
I heard.
So these commercials
are come out now,
where the first one that
was released yesterday
was basically a perspective
of a laborer in a bus,
where he gets into
this car crash.
And this person
starts filming them.
And the tagline is "if it were
your pain, would you share it?"
#PostWisely.
And I was very proud
to be involved in them
because they're very
powerful commercials.
SARA HAMDAN: Wow.
Because the other DU
commercials that come to mind
are all quite funny and light.
This is--
ALI MOSTAFA: No, this is quite--
SARA HAMDAN:
Different direction.
ALI MOSTAFA: --hard-hitting.
It's quite graphic.
And it's about time.
I think we need ads like that.
Because I mentioned to them
when I would go back and forth
to the UK a lot, there used to
be this campaign called think,
where it is about texting and
driving or drinking and driving
or not wearing your seat belt.
And those car accidents, they
used to be quite graphic.
And it would really
leave an impact.
So for a while, I thought
given the amount of accidents
we had here, the
police needed to start
making adverts like that.
So now we started it
with this new campaign.
SARA HAMDAN: That's great.
ALI MOSTAFA: It was cool.
SARA HAMDAN: From your
professional opinion,
then, having worked on so
many different ads, what's
the kind of ad that
really pops or connects
with audiences that you imagine
might go viral on YouTube?
ALI MOSTAFA: Oh.
Well, usually the
funny ones actually
tend to go quite viral.
But something really that people
haven't really seen before,
because it's become--
I mean, the industry's
like a cookie cutter.
I mean, they just keep
copy-pasting similar things,
change the way the person looks.
So when you start doing
something that's more original,
which, by the way, is
next to impossible to do,
it starts when those
things actually go viral.
When you can make someone cry--
and really, when I say
cry, whether they cry
or whether they're impacted
by something or whether they
laugh, when you
tick those emotions,
that's when they want to start
sharing it with other people.
SARA HAMDAN: The emotional role.
ALI MOSTAFA: And it
starts going viral.
But again, it has to
have an original--
SARA HAMDAN: Concept.
ALI MOSTAFA: --concept, yeah.
SARA HAMDAN: OK.
I'd love to hear if you
guys have any questions.
I'm hogging all of the time.
Anybody have any questions?
ALI MOSTAFA: Do we have--
I mean, how long have
we been going for?
I feel like I've been rambling.
SARA HAMDAN: It's
been half an hour.
ALI MOSTAFA: We got time?
SARA HAMDAN: I've
been keeping an eye.
ALI MOSTAFA: OK.
Questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about the film "The Worthy"?
Because it's also
quite [? different. ?]
ALI MOSTAFA: Ah, yes.
OK.
So "The Worthy"
was my third film.
And there was many reasons
I wanted to do "The Worthy."
One of the biggest
ones is that I
didn't have to wait four years.
I was in post-production
for "A to B,"
and Image Nation Abu Dhabi,
they funded half of that movie.
And they had this script
concept called "The Worthy."
And they had two amazing
producers attached to it--
Peter Safran, who produced
"The Conjuring" and "Annabelle"
and those horror films,
and Stephen Schneider, who
did "Insidious" and
"Paranormal Activity."
So these guys made these
blockbuster Hollywood horror
films.
And they had this genre film
idea called "The Worthy."
And it was set in a dystopian
post-apocalyptic world
and about survival and so forth.
And I read the script.
But what I was told is
that I have to take this,
and I have to make it our own,
Arabize it, and try and set it
in the region.
And so like I said, I didn't
have to wait four years.
But also, it was a
genre that I would never
have even thought of doing.
I don't know how many
of you are horror fans.
SARA HAMDAN: No.
ALI MOSTAFA: But I would
not go to the cinema
to watch a horror film.
Doesn't mean I don't
appreciate horror films
or respect the
difficulty in making one.
But it's just not
a thing I would do.
It wouldn't be my first option.
So the fact I've done
an ensemble drama,
I've done a comedy,
this would be
a challenge, something that
I would never think of doing.
And I did it.
And we shot it entirely
in Bucharest, Romania.
So that was a great experience.
And the film is now picked
up by Netflix worldwide.
And so if you want to watch my
third film, it's on Netflix.
SARA HAMDAN: Nice.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So you say
the industry does not
exist as such.
It's not sustainable.
ALI MOSTAFA: Not yet.
AUDIENCE: Do
filmmakers make money?
Did you break even
in your movies?
ALI MOSTAFA: That's
a great question.
Not one.
Not one of the films broke even.
AUDIENCE: Even "City of Life"?
ALI MOSTAFA: Even
"City of Life."
"City of Life" did really well.
But "City of Life" was
a $5 million movie.
You can't make $5
million in ticket sales
in Dubai those days.
It was impossible.
Now one of the
top big box office
hits, the summer
box office hits,
in Dubai could go
up to $2 million,
now, with the amount of cinemas.
So that film needed
to have gone globally.
Although we did sell
in different markets,
still, it's a very
difficult industry
to try and make money with.
That's why you have to start
making films, which is a film
that I would
probably like to do,
that are very low budget
now because you know
you can start breaking even.
So once those films
start happening,
they start to then
become sustainable.
Then you can start
funding your next film.
But unfortunately, my dream
was too big, too early.
So I was making
big-budget movies.
AUDIENCE: So people
actually fund
them knowing that they're
going to lose money?
ALI MOSTAFA: Well, "City
of Life" was the first,
so they had no idea.
[LAUGHTER]
The second one was-- both
were semi-government, who were
trying to start an industry.
And the last one was fully
funded by Image Nation.
And that's their mandate, is
to help create a film industry.
AUDIENCE: Does it come with
strict strings attached?
ALI MOSTAFA: In what way?
AUDIENCE: Creatively.
ALI MOSTAFA: Well, luckily--
usually yes.
Because when I did my
second film, I wrote.
My first film, I wrote.
So I wrote, produced, and
directed the first two films.
This one, I was only
hired as a director.
So usually, yes.
Usually when you're with the
kind of the studio system,
where you're hired as a hired
gun, in the creative side,
you don't necessarily get
final cut of your edits
or how you want it to be.
But what was amazing with,
obviously, Image Nation,
is that not only
are they producers
that are driven to
create this industry,
but they're also
very creative people.
And they support you.
So yes, there was a
lot of discussions.
But all the discussions were
very positive because we all--
I think I'm now
on my third film.
You kind of get what
you're trying to do.
And everyone understands
we're doing this
for the bigger picture
and for everyone
to kind of be happy
with the end result.
So not necessarily now, but
probably it will happen.
But usually, yes.
You do get a lot of constraints.
Like, if I were probably gonna
do a film in Hollywood now,
yeah.
I'd be under reigns for sure.
AUDIENCE: So I'd
like to also get
your thoughts on the
[INAUDIBLE] movie
and just overall, what
do you think is happening
across the Arab world?
Are there directors
you enjoy seeing?
And I'd also like to see, are
there collaborations happening
in Mideast in terms of
how the industry works?
Is there a governing
body or something?
Or there's really
nothing [INAUDIBLE]??
ALI MOSTAFA: No,
we don't really--
OK, the Egyptian cinema
obviously is a huge industry.
Huge industry.
They're their own beast,
their own machine.
But there was a period--
there was the golden
era, and then there
was a period where they
were just producing--
where even Egyptians would
say they were nonsense.
And now they've come back
to start to produce and make
some amazing films again.
I was actually there
recently as a jury member
for the first Gouna
Film Festival in Egypt.
And I saw some incredible films.
I actually saw
"The Insult," which
is now nominated for Best
Foreign film at the Oscars,
which is a Lebanese movie.
And I really liked
that filmmaker.
I liked his previous
work, as well.
Ziad.
And so is there a
real collaboration?
There's trying to be one.
I mean, there's this
Arab Film institute
that's been created so we can
kind of break those borders
and kind of work together.
But I think there's
a bit of time
with that because I made a
film, "From A to B," which
was a Saudi, Syrian,
and an Egyptian,
high-school friends go on a road
trip throughout the Arab world.
So it was a very
pan-Arab movie, right?
And it could have been
the time it was released
or the marketing,
whatever may be.
But it was a film you would
have thought, because it being
so pan-Arab, that it would do
very well with Arab audiences,
like in Egypt or in Jordan
or whatever it may be.
And it didn't.
So it was almost
like you almost felt
that when the Egyptian films
come out here in Dubai, yes,
they get a lot of
Arabs involved.
But a lot of the Egyptians
go to see their films.
A lot of Emiratis will
go see their films.
And a lot of Lebanese
will see their films.
Those films don't necessarily
kind of cross borders
so well, which is a
shame because there
are some Lebanese
films, I believe,
could do really well in Egypt.
Or an Egyptian
film, I mean, they
do really well regardless
given their [INAUDIBLE]
massive population.
But now that we
have Saudi Arabia,
that it decided
to open theaters,
this is one of the
things why it's also
so positive because "City
of Life" released today,
we would have made our
money back, you know?
So the industry is growing.
The fact there's now
Saudis opening cinemas,
the fact there's this Arab
Film Institute is happening--
we have a Lebanese film
who's nominated for an Oscar
this year.
And I think it should win.
I haven't seen the
other contenders.
But since "Paradise
Now," we need one.
And it's important.
But I do think those
borders are gonna drop,
and it is gonna become
a lot more accessible.
Yeah, for sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you
get your films to be
screened in Emirates or Etihad
in-flight entertainment?
ALI MOSTAFA: I was very lucky.
Actually, my first
film, "City of Life"--
actually, I should
not talk about that.
But my first film,
"City of Life"
was in Emirates, although
we had a flight attendant
and we had an airline
in "City of Life."
But I had to make one up.
But after the fact, Emirates
were very supportive
and saw that it was
something that was important.
They put it as the
first film on in-flight.
I think it was on the plane
for, like, two months.
They put me on the cover
of "Open Skies" magazine.
I was interviewed during--
while people would see the
opening film of the safety,
after that, there was me giving
an interview on "City of Life."
So they were very supportive.
"A to B," obviously, had some
Etihad exposure in the film.
So it was played in Etihad.
Actually, it was also
played in Emirates.
But there were certain
scenes that were removed.
And yeah, so the airlines
are very supportive.
We're very lucky to have
the airlines, the press.
They're excited.
I mean, I think everyone's as
hungry to have a film industry,
also.
SARA HAMDAN: You had
a question back there.
AUDIENCE: What was the reaction
from the general public
in Dubai-- can you break it
down in terms of expats versus
locals--
to some of the controversial
subjects in the movie?
Has it stimulated the debate
about Dubai's identity
[INAUDIBLE].
ALI MOSTAFA: You see,
I guess the movie that
comes to mind,
obviously, would be
"City of Life" for me in that.
Because when that film was
released in the theaters,
and I was going to the
cinema to watch, let's say,
another movie, I would
pass by the hall.
And I would hear
my film playing.
And I would tell the
usher, just one second.
I just want to take a
quick look from the back.
And I would just step
in every now and then
in the theaters to see reaction,
but also to see the audience.
And it was such a huge mix
of different nationalities.
There was the Indian community.
You had the Western
community, the Emiratis,
and all of them sitting
there watching this one film.
What I found unfortunate
is that that is slowly--
because it was such a film that
spoke to so many nationalities,
that I feel it's unfortunate
that we have not now
made Emirati films of
a standard, as yet--
when I see Emirati,
like, pure Emirati--
that can bring in an
international audience
to watch it, too.
I think once we reach
that stage where
we make a fully Arabic-spoken,
Arabic-produced, cast Emirati
film and still have a
similar audience, that
will go to show that
we've reached a level
where we're now
speaking to Dubai.
And what is Dubai?
Dubai is such a
multicultural place.
So I think you need a
bit more time with that.
SARA HAMDAN: You can test
it out by doing a YouTube
show, a series, episodes.
Just putting that out there.
ALI MOSTAFA: I would love
to do a series on YouTube,
but not one of those
kind of blogger, selfie,
influencer ones now.
That's not something I can do.
I'm not good at that.
SARA HAMDAN: I'm a blogger.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question related to the--
ALI MOSTAFA: Well, but
you're a good blogger.
I'll be a terrible blogger.
SARA HAMDAN: I'm just kidding.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question related to when
you work with advertisers.
ALI MOSTAFA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said that
it's very difficult
to do something different.
ALI MOSTAFA: I don't blame
the advertising, though.
I blame the clients.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
But I want to understand
what other kind of friction
you have with them in trying
to pitch new ideas or new kind
of--
ALI MOSTAFA: You know, I've also
been very lucky where clients
sometimes approach me directly.
And they approach
me, and they say,
listen, we have this product, or
we have this-- whatever it be,
this car, this resort.
Would you be able to
make an ad or film on it?
That's when we can go back,
and we can start creating ideas
ourselves.
And you skip the
whole middleman.
And because they
approach you directly,
they kind of listen
to what's going on.
But when you have the
client, the agency, and then
the production, unfortunately,
a lot of the times,
you end up giving up the
fight because you realize,
is it really worth it?
But sometimes you really like
the commercial or the content
or the copy, and you really try
and fight it to make it better.
But unfortunately, I feel it's
the client that needs to be
more educated on what they can
or cannot show or understand
film.
Because there's
a lot of the time
you would have this person who
might be the head of marketing
for whatever company
who has no idea
or has no background about what
is a good commercial, what's
a bad commercial.
It's pure feeling on the day.
I had an instance where I
was shooting a certain car
commercial many years ago, where
the head marketing of that car
brand decided, after I
edited the director's cut,
came in the next day, edited
the whole film himself,
and then released it.
And I said, you have to
remove my name from that.
Because it's not
what I had done.
So there's a lot of the
times where-- obviously, it
wasn't very good.
So it's more about educating,
I think, the client and also
having the agency to
be a little bit more,
I guess, courageous
with the approach.
Because there's always
this time where they say,
we don't want to
upset the client.
Well, it's your job.
They're paying
you a lot of money
to tell them what is creative,
what is cool, and what is not.
Right?
That's not theirs.
That's why you are there.
And once that happens,
once the client
becomes confident and accepts
what the agency have to do,
then I think the
content in the region,
because we have the
capabilities to produce,
is that they're going
to be a lot better.
SARA HAMDAN: I think that's
all the time we have,
unfortunately.
But it's been an amazing talk.
Thank you so much for
sharing your stories with us.
ALI MOSTAFA: Thank you.
SARA HAMDAN: And I hope that
we get to host a little--
ALI MOSTAFA: It was
an absolute pleasure.
SARA HAMDAN: --Oscars party for
you here in this very room--
ALI MOSTAFA: [INAUDIBLE]
SARA HAMDAN: --in a few
years for your YouTube show.
ALI MOSTAFA: God willing.
SARA HAMDAN: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]